also erstens ich erahne aus ihrer frage
dass sie kein besonderer freund des
impfens sein könnten
aber wenn sie wenn sie ansonsten alle
impfstoffe akzeptieren nur nicht die mrm
stoffe dann kommt sicherlich auch für
sie als jemand der gerne in anderen
impfstoff hat die zeit wo sie diesen
impfstoff auswählen können ich glaube
schon dass das so ist soll auch menschen
geben die das sage ich vollkommen
neutral wir wollen nämlich keine
impfpflicht einführen die eben sich
nicht werden impfen lassen wenn das mehr
als 40 50 60 prozent der bevölkerung
seien solchen dann werden wir noch sehr
lange eine maske tragen müssen
es war sehr viel länger als das weil wir
dann die herdenimmunität nicht erreichen
oder wenn das in anderen ländern der
welt platziert
das liegt in der natur der sache dass
impfen können sie zu dem zeitpunkt wir
haben eine priorisierung wenn aber
nachher alle impfstoffe da sind in
ausreichender menge dann wird sicherlich
auch die möglichkeit bestehen dass man
sagt man möchte diesen impfstoff und
nicht den anderen bei m wir werden
allerdings auch sagen welche impfstoffe
welche gruppe vielleicht am besten
geeignet sind das wissen wir heute noch
nicht
und dann würde ich sie bitten der sache
dem sachverhalt entsprechend nicht von
irgendwelchen genmanipulierten dingen zu
sprechen das ist ein impfstoff der
genetische komponenten enthält und damit
sehr präzise funktionieren könnte so
jedenfalls die jetzigen laborergebnisse
versuchsergebnisse der phase 3 studien
angesehen
friedrich möchten sie noch eine
nachfrage stellen muss nicht sein
das muss nicht sein die elternrechte
sind an keiner weise angegriffen da die
ja in der regel diejenigen sind die für
ihre kinder
die rechte umsetzen und demzufolge
höchstes interesse daran haben deswegen
kann ich ihnen von der stelle
zustimmung signalisieren dass wir sowohl
die kinderrechte videotext empfehlen
sagt das ist doch schön dass die
koalitionsverhandlungen ab dann stellt
die nächste frage
liebe kollegen wie ich mir die bemerkung
erlauben darf wir sollten fragestunde
regierung befragen nicht zu sehr zu
koalitionsverhandlungen um zu
funktionieren so die meinung meiner
verantwortung als präsident dieses
parlaments ist aber jetzt stellt die
nächste frage völlig unverdächtig dass
es koalitionsverhandlungen seien während
der kollege reinhard houben fdp
manchmal herr präsident hat ja
vielleicht die opposition auch interesse
einen einblick in das innenleben der
regierung zu bekommen aber war wusste
ich dass die bereitschaft der opposition
in zukunft auch regierungsverantwortung
tragen dadurch zu sehr eingeschränkt
frau bundeskanzlerin also aus meiner
erfahrung heraus scheint das interesse
in den koalitionsfraktionen größer zu
sein als bei den oppositionsfraktionen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren